drug smuggling networks are expanding
across the UK from cities into rural
areas it's called county lines and the
leading expert on this issue has told us
that this industry is now worth 3
million pounds a day it's brought with
us a wave of violence involving children
now a lots been talked about this issue
but we're going to take you right into
the heart of the operation and we're
going to start in what's called a trap
house here in North London
it's where drugs are prepared sold and
used
so just tell me a little bit about how
much you do what kind of things you sell
that sort of thing everything like
performance and you can get crushed and
get caught and get a leave anything you
want as long as you want don't move be a
supply and is that a good demand yeah
anyway I'll see what's what's been the
impact on your life day money money yeah
cuz I'm cautiously what stop smoking
hunter stop
I'm sure money's gone yeah
yeah all your money goes towards yeah a
little spare money yeah yeah the money
right want to start on stuff
so do you mostly sell in the area in the
area most of it outside of London right
and how does that work as much as you
can tell me how does that work Oh me my
buddy over yeah you'll find one crack it
I'll give them some rocks without
normals I refer their icon for their for
their using earth
I see yeah so that's just you're
building up your conten your contacts
list in that heavy so you'll go on a
little day trip somewhere say right find
the bit find a crackhead get how was the
areas established I'm a lord up you know
I'll make a nicer mom I will go out
leave the area
I'm good I'll get kids to go up there
for me and how much you pay them feeling
like 300 300 a week say what's our age
of all four maybe at all like 15 16 how
do you how do you find these kids
yeah how do you recruit you need money
mommy and daddy ain't got no money so he
didn't come today from - uncle uncle
send em send them hard there that don't
have a week a week two weeks in be tough
then they'll deal with it after deal so
we have to do that one
good what's boot camp boot cut other
side of London yeah trained in one so
you take you go with them once distant
to everybody I'm doing one show a short
um how it works you know wants to get a
hang of it I'll slip the beer the kids
that I meet who are the ones that are
what they were called the collateral you
know the ones that are doing the
operational stuff on the ground being
groomed these are often small vulnerable
children who look like me don't have
much confidence aren't really able to
carry a conversation with you don't want
to look you in the eye most kids
basically within that a scared stiff my
mum had it without Scambler mold
bubblers would imprison me my little
Baba become and say well doesn't at home
I got put into a caring I got involved
with the wrong people met some wrong
older guys they would get me to join
Drock woman what did that involve are we
missing for the whole night which a lot
of people in care do you go miss him
that was often no drop by there no no
money and you're being asked to do what
exactly
so drugs so heroin crack cocaine
everything and did you ever have any
trouble with any other other groups of
people who wanted to sell drugs the same
area or anything like that one of the
dealers actually stopped me because I've
got walked so hang on you got robbed and
you went back he said I haven't got the
drugs so he stabbed you what to punish
you yeah part of the grooming of the
child who's involved in running those
drugs is that they and their first
outing with their phone line which is
the county line and actually the drugs
they're distributing they will be
systematically robbed by other members
of the gangs they don't know that they
will be punished and scorned for being
stupid enough to let that happen and
then they'll be let back in by saying
well it's your first time out we'll give
you another chance but now you owe us
what if we could show you that teenage
drug mules face I think you'd be really
shocked by how young she looks but it
turns out it's not just children who are
varying these drugs for the gangs we're
off to meet the woman in her 40s who is
running a line to South End we've been
told to go to Liverpool Street and that
she'll be carrying two topshop bags
I got involved because my son was going
around
with some friends they were involved in
drugs and all sorts of things
they got him involved as well he asked
me not to tell him so
I've been helping him ever since
the stuff I deliver it I did it to burn
and I leave I don't even talk to them
because I'm scared of them
that people they're not very
they're not nice people and do you know
what's in the package should we describe
just small package and it's wrapped up
very well very tight and well in a lot
of
take every time I do it I'm very scared
because every time you do it you think
you know I'm going to get when you don't
look like
it's not me yeah assistant yeah how's
that
not very nice
not nice at all
it's dangerous you can't go to the place
because the next will be careless if we
do
[Music]
what countenances become as the
expansion of London in all respects in
terms of the violence the knife crime
the young people are involved because
you're expanding a workforce and you're
expanding the geography of your
operation you need more people involved
you can no longer run around a London
borough with six people doing drugs if
you're then also covering six counties
and a dozen towns and that's where the
young people come in young people in
Southend told us this inflow of drugs
has come with an explosion of violence
this group lost a friend in a stabbing
earlier this year he had a bit of an
argument with a boy and they were
bickering between him and it got very
heated and a boy stabbed him and he
ended up dying yeah he was a drug dealer
involved in drugs had quite a big drug
line if I try to recruit you what sort
of things today even if like you're not
looking for it if you're trying to avoid
it you can just walk down the street and
just turn around the corner and the
group of people will just approach you
and then know to say are you from around
these are shielded the question is
overlap or even people not from around
here I've had people who've got off the
train from London and just come up to me
and I said and you want to make money
with me come come work with me luck I'll
give you this I'll give you that it's
really
it's become a drunk Peter quince because
you're wearing all that fancy clothes
and you have getting that money kids
nowadays that will walk around town sent
our we've a bag of drugs and a knife and
a knuckle duster and now I think it's
appropriate and these kids are like 12
13 years of age do you carry weapon them
it depends at times if I'm walking home
late or I'm out late I will I will
like I've had to because I've had
certain problems with people about and
just serve threats and large just felt
like but the safety of Milla I'm not
going to look to use it but if I'm in a
situation where my life threatens luck
and yeah I will use them in the place
that this lot trouble seems to find
anyone and everyone and sure enough as
we're talking things kick off yards away
from us
they just think obviously they just
fourteen-year-old boys they called
himself 12-block they just think they're
serious but they're really not obviously
the piece because obviously bag of studs
in my head and off Monday they just
think they're serious you know tell me
what happen when you got stabbed this
quite recent last Monday and an outside
the bottom of my boys block before a few
of my powers a victim in it you know
some 26 year old man come up behind me
stabbed me in the head with a cup for a
razor blade stab me in my head it six
enemy as long for you centimeters into
my head once in my finger wants my
shoulder armpit arm he's some boy have
me 20 pounds I took my 20 pound off him
what you would do and then it was his
run off like so hit this kid who was who
I got my money off he was selling doctor
this older person and then he was giving
me frets all the time and then next
minute noise rid off his runner yeah
what he owed me anyways and his runner
told him and then he came stab you yeah
to protect his runner now just to show
you Prince of war just to show a south
end everyone get stepped in South End
run if your reputation is I will stab
people if they let me down if you don't
stop the first person unless you down
where do you go from there
what County lines have done is put these
young people out on their own conducting
tasks for these very ruthless people
that are seeing in the Trump houses
organizing all of this do you find where
you get there you've got any problems
with other dealers who want to hit it on
your it is always always put another do
this always
your problem you have to the kids that
dumb kids that go up then give a little
weapon you know this get them happy
telling me giving us some money yeah
we're doing some anyone can get yeah
anyone can get this Marty you are you
come over
step on my toes yeah I know you know our
business you get shocked time you get
shot you shot in your face you can start
doing it whatever them I hear you are
going little boy for a grown man anyone
can get you step on my toes yeah I often
find myself thinking about what's what
is the difference between child soldiers
in Central Africa being desensitized by
being watched or being forced to watch
killings sometimes without their own
families and what's happening in in
parts of county lines at the moment and
I think there's very little difference
in the two this about desensitizing the
use of a knife to plunge into someone
else and kill them if you need so we
need to understand what drives a
fifteen-year-old to even be able to
plunge a knife into the body of someone
else in 21st century Britain this is my
reality you know seeing people don't
seem to get a shot seeing people get
stuck seeing pregnant women smoke crack
that's my reality yeah normal this is
just normal to me no effect means
nothing if they're coming to get me
they'd better cool but you don't kill me
I'm talking about to cool down you've
got a knife right there yeah no this is
not mine this is a little kids this is
this is just a little this will give to
the people when they little kids when
they're gone
it's 4:00 a.m. and we're with Essex
Police and their biggest ever County
lines Operation Sky News has learned
that a push by the National Crime Agency
has led to 500 arrests in the last two
weeks days the cumulation of 21 warrants
were significant arrests were for
conspiracy and also possession of
controlled substances in the local
district Epping Forest these guys though
are not just dealing in this area right
they're not there they're going far and
wide we've had interactions with
colleagues in Crewe Norwich throughout
the United Kingdom well these people
simply fairly high up the food chain you
can see they've got thousands of pounds
worth of cash that was hidden in the top
of this cupboard here and there are
specks of these wads of cash in every
room if he was a betting man and there
were all hundreds she grabbed a number
of the individuals that were arresting
this morning a bit early curry knives
they'd been arrested and Priestley
stopped with knives and some I've got
previous arrests for both attempted
murder and murder we've been trying
again discard his phone officers were
quick enough to get to him we found the
fire we found the Associated battery for
that it's likely that we'll never be out
our drug line phone that's key to this
particular individual so this this
basically is the county line drugs phase
the county line crook phone we've gone
from a position where only a very small
number of police force in the UK were
identifying county lines to a position
now where we think that there were
county lines operating either to or from
every single force area
the Home Office's funded a new catalyzed
Coordination Center where the NCAA is
working with police forces to coordinate
the national efforts to respond to it to
build a better intelligence picture and
to understand how we can respond most
effectively
it does feel like County lines is an
exceptional business model these guys
could be running Amazon quite frankly
the way that their packaging stuff and
shipping it around the country do you
think that we have lost sight of giving
opportunity to young people and that's
this this is a problem that we've
created ourselves well I think it's two
things if you ask kids that are involved
what would have stopped them you know
what about the job that say well what
job could I get that would give me the
kind of career prospects and the you
know financial rewards that I can get
here and also the feeling of belonging
them being part of something at the same
time the gangs exploit that they will
say that you're never going to get a job
now especially if they've had some
problems with the law you might as well
stay with us the best way in my opinion
is the targeted targeted little kids
while you're young ya know that's the
best of the best vehicles once they're
young demise of one they start off
really young and they get older and
older and they have to carry on doing
it's it's the only thing they know it's
the only thing they know what to do I
don't know where this is gonna stop
how it's going to stop
and if it's gonna stop
[Music]